[Music]
hey everybody welcome to simulation I'm
your host Nick hummus and today I will
be interviewing your usual host Alan
Saki on thank you for having me Mick
absolutely it's my pleasure this is a
fun experience for me
simulation yeah it's how does the how
does the guest chair feel the guest here
is very interesting it is it's because
after sitting there whatever 200 times
and asking the other person questions
this is very interesting and plus you're
really close friend of mine which I yeah
I really like that it's you know yam in
this sense but also does this view is
interesting you know it's you don't get
to see the globe in the next map of San
Francisco
yeah no I I've been here since like
basically the beginning of simulation
and I feel like you have so much to say
that like you're always asking people
questions you're always interviewing and
you get a little bit of your own side of
things but like we don't get to ask you
questions and I feel like that's
something that just needs to happen at
some point you know yep yeah let's do it
yeah let's do it I'm happy that you
wanted to do this and talk about these
questions that you have lined up to ask
me this will be fun cuz you're very
Polymathic you have strong mental
lattice so I'll hit the tennis ball back
and I'm sure the conversation will be
really good I'm excited for it yeah
let's do it
so I want to start out like I I think
there's a lot of people who shout out to
Google Earth quick we love Google Earth
yes it's just gorgeous and we like it's
an earth pretty I know I know I just I
mess around with this all the time I
just want someone to shout out by the
way by the way for those that don't know
and Nick's actually a Googler he's a
roboticist he's a polymath so anyway all
his Twitter's in the body can go check
him out more detail Nick and I actually
met in in college our freshman yeah
which was eight years ago which is crazy
to think about that
but so now with your eight years later
in the Bay Area
you had a question I just wanted to do
say that quick this is me yeah yeah you
see you see you're not in this chair
okay
yes oh shut up Alan so I wanted to start
off like I think there's a lot of people
who are new mirja simulation and haven't
seen all the way going back to the
beginning which was was that two years
ago yeah it's like the first show was
with Aubrey de Grey in October of 2017
so that's there for 14 14 months 14 14
months ago yeah yeah I think there's a
lot of people who like haven't been
around to adapt much oh yeah yeah who
haven't seen all of that and I like has
I have because can you can you talk a
little bit about like how you started
simulation like how you went from just
being Alan and being the guy who you are
- I want to do this project good
question good question
all right so let's see here well
just a very insatiable appetite for
knowledge okay and a strong desire to
surround myself with very smart powerful
nodes in the global sphere ones that are
bringing lots of impact to the world
strong value that other people can self
actualize with that we can remove
structural violence --is that impede
people from self-actualization and that
obviously that ethic of mine has evolved
till today so back when things were
starting it wasn't so clearly defined
right the mission of filling sports
stadiums with curious intellectuals
wasn't so clearly defined back in 14
months ago 14 months ago it was really a
list of very powerful questions that I
just wrote down and then sent a bunch of
powerful people in my network and I got
a lot of replies back from those
powerful people saying things like this
is the best list of interview questions
ever you got it go and like really ask
us questions and so I was like alright
let's start doing now let's start asking
these questions to powerful leaders on a
show and whatnot and so then we started
it and it was very quirky because as you
know 14 months ago we literally had like
a mixing bowl yeah you were like drawing
questions out of that that was really
fun it was just quirky cuz yeah it's all
random in that sense and anyway so that
yeah we've evolved quite a bit since
then but it customs from this insatiable
desire to to learn as well as then have
this video content available for other
people around the world to be able to
access free of cost
never any pay walls on our content
there's so many pay walls on the
Internet enough with the pay walls find
other ways to fund the artists and
entrepreneurs around the world instead
of making pay walls so that the poorest
people in the world can't access it I
think that's ridiculous and I'm a strong
supporter of artists and entrepreneurs
that
that that asked for five or ten or 20
bucks for their endeavors like right
away give everyone give as soon as you
can to those people because they are
trying to go build their own path away
from the normal pathway system yeah but
I think there's also like to that point
I think there's a lot of people who you
know especially like kids like high
schoolers who maybe can't do that
and I think that's okay too like I think
just naturally in terms of a big part of
your mission is like reaching so many
people that like you would expect that
most of the people who you're trying to
reach who you're trying to share with
really can't they can't contribute and
that's okay yeah like that that's almost
your model or he's that's right I think
that is a model working as intended yes
if you are if you are in low SES never
contribute to what we're doing until
you've made your way out to them to mid
SES socioeconomic status because
sometimes yeah sometimes when you only
have a couple dollars it can also be
very interesting to give you know one of
your dollars to you know to someone else
and just see how that makes you feel and
see what it does but you're right those
systems working exactly how it's
supposed to be working when the poorest
people in the world they're able to
watch this to some degree of cost and
hopefully learn something from it get
inspired by going build with it manifest
their destiny into the world yeah yeah
and it's interesting like if you only
have a little giving of what you have
really means a lot too
yeah yeah that's right that's right yep
yeah yeah a proportion of the total
amount of money yeah yeah yeah it's
interesting so another thing I wanted to
ask you yes and I think this struck me a
little bit after after your event last
night but like that one is with uh dr.
Adam Zelly
yeah who's a world famous neuroscientist
entrepreneur author investor professor
and that was a really fun event about
neuroscience and about mental health and
about solutions to a lot of our
technology addictions and augmenting
human intelligence I love that so yeah
shout out to Adam shoutout to that event
and I'm glad you were there Nick's
actually been around for a long time
being out with even our science comedy
show that we started before that it's
been mixed nick introduced me to FIRST
Robotics which is why he's a roboticist
and he got me involved judging and I'm
seeing game announcing and stuff and I
love those kids anyway yes after the
event yeah
so I this kind of struck me like I want
to ask what does a day in the life of
Alan Sakyong look like well Nick just
watched me Nick just watched me upload
the cognition crisis video so I so after
the cognition crisis is this is a good
question so the show was at the show was
at 8 p.m. yesterday on Friday the
December 14th and around in the morning
sometime around like 10 I think ish 9 or
10 I was beginning to put together the
equipment with Iran Vargas around Vargas
is the producer and director of the show
and he's the various preferred technical
director Ron Viacom of course you've
heard of him
and we're putting together the equipment
and we're making sure we have everything
so that means that means robotic cameras
that means control surface for the
robotic cameras that means a TriCaster
mini that means tripods that means
lights that means tripods for the lights
that means all of the cabling that means
all of that equipment or making sure you
don't forget things so that's like three
Pelican cases three big cable bags and
it's and it's in the four tripod so this
is a lot of equipment that we're talking
about and then and that's fantastic is
that's a life switching system which
enables you to not have to switch back
between cameras during premiere and Ron
is able to control the robotic cameras
with the control surface instead of half
the camera operate manually controlled
control surface that was 9:00 to 10:00
then at 10:00 it was a very hardcore
focus on everything that needed to be
done in order
to get the event rolling in its fullest
fruition this means talking to a lot of
the local Bay Area influencers that we
know and making sure that they know
about the event again like hey have you
guys are you guys coming do you guys
need some like some ticket comps to the
influencers have you guys promoted it
yet like we're gonna be rolling really
hot tonight we're really excited for
this event that kind of a thing and so
that's so that was really fun because
you know it gets the juices starting to
flow and then I'm reviewing the material
that I've written about Adam and so I've
known Adam now for about two years and
so and I love you know his book the
distracted mind and so I was reviewing
that book that I read last year and I
was meshing together the notes from his
cognition crisis piso synthesizing those
things plus Achille his company that is
working on digital medicine and
literally prescribing video games as
therapeutics for ADHD PTSD Parkinson's
all these apps ting things and and I
that's probably around noon then around
you know then around then at some point
I finally end up showering and shaving
and getting together the the sort of the
the final touches on on the evening like
making sure that all of the you know we
literally have to run to Trader Joe's we
have team Anthony carousel is an amazing
member of our team as well he does a lot
of the event photography and he also
does the he'll you know he'll swoop up
to our back door here around like 4:30
and the event remember the doors open at
7:00 show starts at 8:00 so at 4:30
we're moving all of this equipment into
his car we are lugging it all of that
equipment to Trader Joe's with us
because we have to go to Trader Joe's to
buy food because the event is you know
our ticketing is one of the ways that we
provide ourselves with revenue and so
I've went through this in our video
about the life of running a YouTube
channel and that's also the life of
running
business and so one of our main streams
of Revenue besides patreon is ticket
sales so our tickets are 35 bucks that
includes food and drink and a ticket to
the performance and that means beer wine
and an array of food and so that means
we're going to Trader Joe's and for
those that can't afford to come we give
full scholarships and that's written in
the in the description of the events is
we offer full scholarships to Louis es
people which is extremely important to
us again yeah very barrier of entry is
is for techies that make 100k pay 35
bucks support a local artist for low SES
people I can't afford email us a free
ticket no problem so a huge part of our
ethic and then and then yeah so then we
go and we get all that grub from Trader
Joe's and then we go to drop it off at
all that grub and and the equipment at
work wise and and then we set up all the
equipment we luckily have volunteers
like Nick we have Steven we have Jordan
we have a really strong team of people
that that come and help us actually this
is really important as you build
something into the world you got to get
people that are that see that you're
bringing value and that you ask to help
you and to see if they're interested in
helping you and keep building value keep
building relationships and then soon you
can get the whole earth behind your back
hire well that's one of the things that
I mentioned in the in the TEDx talk that
I gave was ideas spread from an
individual to the community to the world
and so if we can get the world believing
in the fact that we need to have more
thought-provoking questions to AH
provoking conversation discourse nuance
driven multidisciplinary discourse about
the future of civilization removing
structural violence as all the stuff
which is this is the big ethical our
show that it will actually happen and to
finish this off we host the event the
event is fantastic you know we're
obviously coordinating having all the
guests there coordinating this with
work-wise our venue which we love
work-wise they're the future
work and then afterward so the event you
know the event executes it's super fun
we have a we had Paco Romain and local
Berry a comic open up the show for ten
minutes then we had Adam and I sit down
for an hour and discuss through the
notes that I was talking about earlier
very rough rough so we can tangent we're
a lot and then QA about 30-40 minutes QA
and then we close the show when you
close the show those three Pelican cases
three bags for tripods two lights etc
we're packing all that back up we're
moving that back to the studio so that's
you know that's a tremendous amount of
work and we're networking with people
people are networking with each other
it's hella fun and that's and you know
hilariously enough that's not the end of
my night so after waking up at 9:00 and
doing that event I come back and I you
know Nick and Anthony are down here
talking about the universe and talking
about all this interesting stuff to me
and I'm thinking like I have to pump out
this content as in we usually livestream
our shows and we only we recorded our
show instead of live-streaming it and it
can sometimes be hard to get any third
connection and then you get a two-hour
show instead of what we have now which
we uploaded which is a one-hour talk
with Adam then a 35 or whatever meet at
QA and then a five-minute highlight reel
so I was able to chop segments I'll put
him at the beginning to entice people to
watch etc so just to finish this up I I
went and worked all night from midnight
until 8:00 a.m. and I I did all that I
went into premiere and I made the intros
the outros I made the cut pieces out
from the middle of our talk and put it
at the beginning to entice people to
watch it in a very enticing format and
then it takes hours it takes hours that
we won't we you know we woke up maybe
around like 11:00 11:30 so we three
hours three and a half hours sleep for
me and then immediately when I woke up
for the last two hours I've been making
thumbnails to those videos I've been
making tags making BIOS posting all
these videos across social media because
the ball is still hot people remember
the
event they want to see the content I
have a backlog of 20 interviews to still
edit I need to get this [ __ ] out so it's
worth it for us to [ __ ] execute and
get [ __ ] done go and build stop being
lazy stop you're when your attention is
fragmented you are not manifesting your
destiny you you're top-down neural
architecture top-down processing needs
to be fueled by you putting everything
away and executing for eight straight
hours like I did last night and that's
how you get [ __ ] done focus and get [ __ ]
done turn all your notifications off use
those devices as one-way communication
tools
I mean preach for a long time Nick is
ready to ask another question that's the
life of a day when we do an event and I
have a fuckload of video to edit so
that's that's a that's it that's a day
your focus is really incredible Thank
You hummus love you love you man thank
you thank you yeah so the next thing I
wanted to ask like you were getting back
into like talking about all these
thought-provoking questions and if I
answer for 15 minutes of questions so
we'll never end of what I asked you one
okay yeah got a thought-provoking one so
those were good questions Alan what do
you think of you've outlined and I
remember your original 20 questions you
had so many questions so many pressing
issues yeah things that were top of mind
for you then and many of them still are
now of those problems or maybe a new one
what do you think is the biggest problem
that faces our species our civilization
our planet and what do you think will
end up happening to address that mmm
such a good question Tim hmm biggest
problem facing our species and what
we'll do to solve that yeah well let's
put it this way
civilization has evolved grace in men in
many ways just so luckily and gracefully
out of four and half billion years of
evolution earth orbiting the star and
that is a miracle in itself that life
evolved to this pinnacle of a human mind
that has now build civilizations the
fact that we don't have gratitude in our
daily embedded souls for the fact that
we are here living amongst each other so
beautifully and we're not celebrating
and and you know on a like on a daily
basis carrying around a spirit of like
[ __ ] yeah it's amazing that we're all
live in sharing this collective
experience together seven in that seven
point seven billion of us that that that
is it's disheartening that we don't have
that sort of a love and communion with
each other communion with nature and
evolution that goddess here I think
that's the biggest problem that faces
our species is that we don't have a
collective sense of unity as planet
Earth as Earthlings moving forward and
because we could tackle [ __ ] anything
we want anything anything we want if we
had that collective sense of unity and
just we knew how to maximize our full
potential and also the resource flows
that enable individuals to collectively
maximize their potential a lot of it has
to do with degrees of freedom one's
ability to pursue what they want
shout out to man Wade we have so much
like social fragmentation from all the
tribalism that our species has taken on
as part of how we've become where we are
today how do we really move past that oh
the solution yeah yeah the solutions are
good that's a good hit Nick's like get
to the solution look at look at this
look at this blue marble blue and green
marble it's freaking gorgeous the fact
that we all freakin live here
everyone everyone lives everyone you
ever know everyone you've ever known all
100 billion humans that have lived and
died before us today to build this
beautiful civilization and all of the
species I think it's a hundred million
species that have been around and now
it's ten million so 90 million are gone
10 million species left approximately
and it's just um it's just interesting
we'll species naturally extinct it's not
all species species yes yes so so the
solution um you know because I have the
questions you know let me see what I can
let me see what I can pull here well and
a one that I think is not difficult to
ask of people to do and that is also the
most accessible thing on the planet is
people's breath breath people's breath
so if you join me Nick
turning off the visual stimuli of the
eyes and taking these long inhales and
exhales ain't grateful for the fact that
we're even alive here in breathing just
feeling feeling our bodies feeling our
hearts this is the type of stuff that's
[ __ ] free it's free it's free to do
this and to ground yourself into that
that feeling and then when you ground
yourself into that feeling you gain a
greater sense of gratitude for for you
and your body and just and just feeling
in general and then you can help take
that feeling and a great a sense of
compassion and empathy for earth as a
unity as a union with evolution species
other humans etc so I think that breath
breath is a very interesting breath is a
very interesting solution and it's been
passed down for thousands of years and
it's just that a lot of people are
running around in the economic and
political machinery of civilization
that's what we're doing nowadays in in
many ways that doesn't maximize one's
ability to connect deeply with their own
soul and their heart and their own self
work and who they are know thyself
self-awareness and then the ability to
bring value to other people and help
civilization so that's my that's my
interact with you what do you what do
you think of that Hamas I mean that
actually that also makes me think back
to what like some of the stuff note Adam
was talking about last night like in
this attention economy like it's so easy
to not take that space between stimulus
and action
consider what how to proceed and to just
react
it's as if like this breathing this
mindfulness has been a part of at least
a part of human culture for a long time
and it's only gotten harder as our
technology has done good and bad things
for us that's right that's that's a good
that's a really good connecting point
from from last night Adam taught us
about the pause being one of the main
things that makes humans different than
every other species and that in that
moment that pause that mindful ability
for us to breathe that just be present
in that moment and think about our our
hearts but also our goals and what we
care about rather than going immediately
for oh my god I'm bored right now I'm in
line I got information forage you know
you know it's it's um so anyway yeah
that's a really that's a really good
connecting point Nick yeah yeah good
stuff this is very interesting very
interesting this is very interesting
yes so I'm gonna ask the next question
and I want to own her mind everybody
like Alan doesn't know what I'm asking
next oh yeah that's true fantastic I
love that part about it it's fresh that
way yeah it's it's authentic it's fresh
and real yeah I purple I doubt we're
doing it this way yeah yeah so another
question I wanted to ask and I think we
should touch on this a little bit
already okay but like what what is your
brand like oh that's interesting yeah
not only simulation but like Alan sakya
yeah yeah what is your personal yeah
yeah that's good that's a great question
[Music]
it isn't beatboxing my my that is part
of the brand it's the ability to just be
silly and you know free think and not be
so worried about what other people are
saying but there's so much more the main
aspect of the brand you know there's a
very good quote by just click on that
silliness point a dr. Seuss quote that
not that I like nonsense because it
wakes up the brain cells and so yeah
nonsense is [ __ ] amazing and so if
you can be like do pretty but even a
little bit you know you can just mess
around and it just it liven things up
and it just it makes things not
Conformity sucks so what is the brand of
alan what's you know I don't even really
know the name Alan and you know it's you
know it's a beautiful divine thing that
everyone gives given their name their
first name in their last name and that's
beautiful and divine in many ways but
the same time it's also like that just
just like I don't want my Alan has
nothing to do with civilization
civilization has so much more my little
80-year spark of life and death those
two voids of life and death and my 80
years in between if a grain of sand on
the cosmic scale and evolutionary scale
and my impact on earth is so again a
grain of sand less so the brand of Alan
and more so you know what can we really
do how can we how can we are meant the
perception of civilization to care more
about that unity that collective feeling
of prosperity tickity
they're moving forward and so that's my
that's the brand that's the brand of of
simulation that's the brand of Allens
that's the brand but the general idea is
just you know whether it's simulation
Allen whatever you know don't eat not
even associating it with a brand I know
broods or power but just carrying that
augmentation and perception if you have
more organizations can just carry that
augmentation perception of the unity and
desire for collective prosperity and how
just great grateful and humble we are to
even be here together celebrating like a
big party and taking great care of Earth
and birthing out of the womb into the
cosmos I love that stuff NIC that's
that's um that's your mind that's my
answer
I I think you just managed to answer my
next question as well oh great but I'm
gonna see if you have anything to add
okay what is your mission okay okay
I think I think a main part of just
something to add to that well yeah this
is good that you asked about adding to
it is there's a lot of structural
violence --is that impede people from
self-actualization and it's extremely
important for us to eradicate those
structural violence as as soon as
possible so giving someone a degree of
freedom is extremely important meaning
people don't on earth don't have some
people don't have basic necessities for
survival access to clean water access to
electricity access to food access to
shelter access to education health care
these types of things and so the the the
tiniest thing that we the biggest thing
we can do but it's such an interesting
ly tiny thing it's not to go in like we
deliver fresh water to places that don't
have fresh water because that's like a
band-aid it's better to actually empower
the local communities there to find the
sources of fresh water and fresh food to
job growth as in if they can if they can
actually find a way to prosper in their
local
Unity's by producing something locally
of value and then eliminating the
structural violence is things like
egregious excuse me
egregious forty five percent tariffs
that occur on importing goods into like
places like Senegal other things like
the difficulty it is for to create forms
of government around the world like you
have to take a year's worth of your
salary and then you have to wait a year
in order to be able to start a business
and then if you mess up on some of your
paperwork people can go and corruptly
agree delete reinhold things over your
head these are the things that are
impeding people from prospering with
their degrees of freedom in whatever
ways they desire and so that's something
that is Part D part of the evolving
ethic that we've developed here and that
we want to get out as soon as possible
around the world this is not just the
United States this is around the world
and it's we'll get there together
everyone just you know one step at a
time we'll be patient and we'll have a
you know we'll have a grassroots
uprising of this increase of self
awareness and collective awareness
slowly but it will happen and we're
gonna obsolete the megalomaniacs those
that are too driven by greed and
corruption and we're gonna drive that
ethic out of civilization it's gonna
we're gonna obsolete that system through
our grassroots movement Wow that's I
think that's not only like a message of
empowering people but I think it really
speaks to like how you see how you see
the future I mean I think so much like
so much of what you talk about you talk
about social problems you talk about
structural problems but you also talk
about like the people like the as it
were the great person theory of history
teaches about that Nick yeah so I mean I
I think in essence it's the idea and
it's a bit of a simplification but it's
the idea that
like a person can be the spark that
changes everything
like butterfly effect so in a sense yeah
yeah but it's that it's not like
structural patterns in society and it's
not inevitable now when you get a person
who's the right person for that time
like the Einstein who goes well there's
all of these ideas but has that unique
spark of inside yeah to really change
things
yeah but of course the great person
theory yeah I like that the great person
and that means you can be the great
person and you can be the great person
and you can be the great person I got a
doozy no I that's good Nick this yeah
yeah I like that a lot but I'm curious
for like so you you talk about so much
in nuance and so many ups and downs and
challenges and potential solutions and
ideas and problems where do you see like
when you think of the future do you
think of it optimistically or do you
think of it like pessimistically are
concerned for the way that the future
will unwind like how do you how do you
see the future
so this is good this is good so first
and foremost is becoming very informed
about the current state of humanity and
then also the history of how humans got
to this place so there's a very
important principle called the Pareto
principle you have to focus so much of
your time and your neural architecture
because there's a limitation in the
amount of time and neural architecture
you can fill and go and parse for the
highest signal this means go and find
the only 20% of information that exists
about the current state of humanity and
the history of humanity that's going to
give you the 80% or more grand picture
the picture of big history of
understanding how civilization got here
and who we are first and foremost so do
that build out your mental lattice
really strongly with the highest signal
possible and focus so that's first look
at this freaking gorgeous
this place it's amazing it's gorgeous
seven seven point seven billion of us
okay so that's first and then that's
realism so that's realism is having this
true real picture of big history first
and foremost and then we carry a sense
of optimism we carry a sense of optimism
about what we talked about earlier in
this show our ability to prosper
collectively and become a pinnacle
civilization in the cosmos and just
ramped up maximize human to the fullest
as it had an individual collective level
and so that's a great sense of optimism
there so it's like an optimistic realist
but but it's extremely important to
still have a very strong realistic
understanding of the negative influences
that still plague the world in terms of
those structural violence --is who is
creating those structural value
why are they purposely what what lead
societal evolution and their individual
mind evolution in their environment to
want to be greedy to want to be corrupt
to want to be violent what led them to
those points ask yourself these
questions what led them there and then
how do we remove the obstacles those
issues that leads people to those to
those feelings so so that's you have the
realistic perspective optimist of
perspective and you also understand the
negatives to obsolete the negatives by
building out the optimistic positives
that would be my okay good questions I
like that so what do you think like as
humanity goes on I know like unity is a
big theme that you've had as you're
talking through this yes but like as
humanity goes and I know you're familiar
with the idea of like a type one
civilization type - yeah car - upscale
Kardashev scale yeah shout out to our
homie car - oh whose car - chefs first
name I'm not sure what's up let's give
let's look at let's go let's give a
proper shout out to a car - of here yes
it is the Kardashev scale is car - if
first name what's debt first by Nikolai
Carter Oh Nikolai Kardashev yes Soviet
astronomer yeah yeah cool so partnership
scale is a method of measuring a
civilizations level of technological
advancement based on the amount of
energy of civilizations able to use
proposed by Soviet astronomer Nikolai
Kardashev in 1964 so just a quick
overview just for people that don't know
because we only talk to us a type one
civilization is one that can harness all
of the power of their planet
a type two civilization can harness all
of the power of their star and a type
three civilization can harness the power
of all of the stars of their galaxy yes
okay so that's that's our that's our
Kardashev scale episode yes it's a
metric of growth right and as humanity
as our civilization grows
what is something that you think is
important that we hold on to it don't
lose sight of mm mm hmm mm hmm very good
question very good question we talked
about breath and breath extremely breath
kinda is that thing that makes us human
that pause that breath really makes us
human the ability to be mindful I'd like
to see us
yeah retain that that that sense of true
ethereal humanity something that's so
subtly beautiful the word in Japanese
for it is Yujin it's a profound sense of
like mystery and beauty of the universe
and
because we are progressing into the age
of of exponential technologies and so
now it's really important to retain some
sort of really in just true mindful
principles of humans and ethics and
morals and compassion and care for each
other now more than ever yeah yeah yeah
to really hold on to our humanity yeah
really yeah what would you answer that
question I mean I I think the thing that
really sticks out to me is like but it
it's kind of two sides of the same coin
it's the sense of wonder and the
inquisitiveness
good that we have like that as we go
into a future where the cosmic
background microwave background is no
longer necessarily detectable and there
are new things and there's only so much
time that we have to learn all that we
can learn like I think like finding out
about ourselves about the universe and
wanting to know more that thirst for
knowledge I know we talk about it like
on the psychological side as like being
information foraging mm-hmm but I think
I think there's a very strong and
powerful side to that as well and I
think I don't I don't want to see us
lose that yeah yeah yeah yeah I have
another question cuz that was really
good Sheriff the sense of wonder and the
sense of excitement to go forth out and
build and create and work together as a
union as we go out learn as much as
possible I would be curious to hear your
thoughts about this yeah prior to what
is it that is it that they call it heat
death of the universe yes all of the
stars go out at some point
yep okay and that's supposedly supposed
to be a couple decade tens of billions
of years yeah yeah dates of yeses of
years yeah tens of billions downloading
so my thought about that then would be
you know okay let's talk
Toad's of billions of years it's
ridiculous that yeah humans are able to
contemplate this kind of stuff my point
is that it wouldn't it be interesting
for us to discover that everything is
kind of recursive in the sense that
civilization advances to the point of
singularity our ability to to have such
a strong union with evolution and
technology and all the power in the
universe all that is in the universe and
make ourselves invincible of the he does
by to the heat invincible through the
heat death of the universe
and then once you get to that point then
it goes right back into the birth of
potentially a big bang and again you
have new worlds forming yes lifes
forming maybe you're maybe you don't
actually maybe on the spark of life and
death after you die maybe you go right
into the next game the next mission that
you're playing to level up your soul
it's exciting stuff on a different rock
with a different civilization that has
evolved what do you think about that
Nick I mean I it reminds me a lot of the
idea of like a Big Crunch that's the
first thing the Big Crunch Oh
are you familiar I think I've told you
have
the universe dying by heat mm-hmm you
have the idea of the universe dying
through cold hmm what if what if rather
than either of those outcomes the
universe is actually cyclic mm-hmm yes
the SICU where the expansion that dark
energy and dark matter are sort of
attached to reverses and everything
comes back to a point mm-hmm before a
new Big Bang boom there is that's that's
it I love it yes I I I'll admit I'm not
up on the latest research on
possibilities for the trajectory of our
you likewise totally but I do love that
idea
me too like that seems it's certainly a
possibility in the future it's a
possibility yeah but I think it's it's a
really poetic one it's a very very
poetic and gorgeous one and I love
thinking about that one and also I'd
like to you know for us to clarify like
you just clarify we don't we're not like
professionals yeah but we also don't
have bias of like attachment towards
that ideology but it's just a poetic
ideology that it's cool to think about
and maybe if the universe is so damn
beautiful like we're pointing out to
maybe that is the truth maybe that is
the beauty is that poetic cyclical yeah
it's gorgeous I mean for as much as the
universe does not care what our
aesthetic preferences are there there
are a remarkably good guide for things
that we should look into as
possibilities because I mean if you
think about and this is something we
were to have talking about earlier like
how Matt drives through and he's
attached to so much of not only how the
universe exists and how physics works
and all of these things but a lot of
like our stetic preferences like the
golden ratio
Gulin ratio you are tied into
mathematics as well and we're able to
describe them in that language yeah so
while it's not like oh yeah this is
something that aesthetically makes
to us therefore it's probably true
things that seem poetic in that way like
that that's an inspiring thing to go I
want to find out about that I want to
see if that's true yeah I want to
research that and like it's not only
personally meaningful to the people who
are doing that
but it's actually not a bad heuristic
yeah yeah I love that one yeah it's a
very powerful heuristic yeah yeah I'm
really happy that you lined that out
yeah yeah so being there with that
feeling of what you just described is so
important I love it I love yeah
like creating meaning through things
that are powerful to you yes period and
that if it also gives us a collective
understanding of reality even all of
that all better
so speaking of things that are like
personally meaningful okay I know one of
your big goals you want to fill a
stadium yes people like who are
celebrating ideas yes
and I anyone cuting them executing
executing them - yeah both and I love
the idea and the symbolism of that and I
frankly like I feel like anybody betting
against that is gonna lose oh really
yeah okay I hope I hope but I'm someone
else can also pull it together yeah yeah
yeah hope I hope so maybe it's not I
hope it's not just you exactly I hope I
hope you people if anything maybe you're
the first but not the last yeah
absolutely but I want to know like you
get there what's your next big goal
after that yes oh my god where do you go
from there okay interesting um well for
sure stadiums filling them around the
world so not just oh yeah not just one
stadium but stadiums around the world
by the time we get to that point I think
we're likely going to have closer to
nine billion people on the planet so it
will be really important to go to these
different diverse areas I mean Africa in
many ways is blossoming to become an
amazing place of potential creative
potential the demographics are so young
and they're gaining access to the most
important basic necessities they're
gonna enable them to flourish I'm super
excited for Africa and so like things
like that
just get me jazzed because that is like
what we could go and do a in Adisa Baba
we could go do one in Ethiopia fill a
stadium there we could go fill a stadium
in two car in Senegal fill a stadium in
Cairo fill a stadium in Lagos and like
that excites me so much to go do that
Africa fill stadiums in South America in
Asia Europe [ __ ] it let's go to camp
Mert oh yeah picnic Myrtle Manor at
McMurdo base the McMurdo base Antarctica
let's so let's go down there all seven
continents all seven I like that shout
out to our homies in intent in its
article look at that gorgeous piece of
ice down there holding yeah it's amazing
it's commonly distorted body by
different projections
yeah the projections look at that let's
that's a beautiful real way to
understand how massive that piece of ice
is yeah because it's on a sphere now
instead of on a 2d Mercator map yeah or
any number of projections that skew it
from being tiny like that little thing
on the bottom to being massive and
oversized compared to what it is yes yes
yes so so stadiums around yeah stadiums
around the world after the first one and
making a culture of stadiums making a
culture of curious intellectuals
gathering to talk about ideas in nuanced
multidisciplinary formats where they're
actually and will eventually get to this
point
- we're don't have the financing and the
structure to be able to do this yet but
we will in our studio as well as our
live events and studio we sometimes put
it up on the on the screen here as we
talk about things but I really want to
actually be able to start writing out
the mental lattice that's being
developed in a sit down so once we sit
down with someone like right now with
Nick we would have had already had you
know in this area we've been talking
about the union of Earth in this area
we're talking about a rally have
structural violence is that way there is
a visual being developed simultaneously
with the conversation I know and I've
talked to a lot of I've messaged the
intellectual dark web about this and I
really want to get this into the large
you know three thousand sea theatres as
soon as possible where we're actually
putting on the projector screen the
mental lattice that's being developed
out as conversation is going and the
visual representation of it so anyway in
the sports stadiums what I'd like to see
in the sports stadiums is the curious
intellectuals coming up building out
this mental lattice and then having
their innovative thoughts that they're
having actually have action items of
execution this group of 1000 curious
intellectuals that really love this idea
of scaling clean meat making it in bio
reactors around the world in the largest
amounts around the world they're gonna
tackle that and they're gonna get clean
meat everywhere as fast as possible in
all those varieties
you know then so I'm talking about like
that so this this is I guess where it
goes next as these pockets of thousands
or hundreds or even just a dozen people
that go off and execute on the on the
ideas that the curious intellectual Wow
stadiums okay so you both want to spread
it like out but also like strengthen it
and turn it from like something that's
not only a like meaningful event I think
for a lot of people but like turn it
into something that is actionable yeah
that's right that's right
of course yeah have that yeah I I think
that really I think that I think that
dovetails nicely like you know I think a
big part of how you
if not how you see the world like how
you interact with the world is like very
entrepreneurial like but that's one
hunted yeah yeah that's right that's
that's how you come at the world it's
one of the my important ways to come at
the world I think there's a lot of
lenses that you take in addition to that
like you talk to psychologists
biologists computer scientists
physicists chemists yes sir
like scientists of just about every
description that I can list off yes sir
an entrepreneur is our to see educators
and the technologists and the
geopolitical scientists and the
emotional intelligence researchers and
all the different types of people
different places of origin across the
earth too so you're building out the
multidisciplinary mental lattice and
like Nick you also got scribed quick I
know you want to go again you describe
something really interesting which was
you described how the stadium idea goes
from it goes from 0 to 1
yeah as tiel says it goes from 0 to 1
the creative thought of figuring out how
to put together the sports stadium in
the first place then it interesting
goodly goes from one to many so goes
across so goes across the world and then
funny enough it cycles right back to
from 1 to 2 so you're going again from 0
to 1 across all these stadiums are then
going and luring up ideas and executing
and then those ideas are spreading again
this is the tree that we've had the
wheel may have so much more the language
made so much more etcetera so that's
what we'll be doing so I just want to
show that yeah your design pattern is
both out yes I love the team yeah but I
wanted to ask like I know
interdisciplinary is yeah a huge concept
yes interdisciplinary is a good way to
put it so is multidisciplinary I like
both of those words a lot I mean I think
they're like close partner they're super
close partners yeah but I wonder like if
not the entrepreneurial yeah we should
quickly explain because I think yeah I
think inter is more about if you smash
together like biotech in neuroscience
yeah we're like biotech and blockchain
or something like that you smash those
that's interdisciplinary disciplinary is
the like the lattice as you might say
like that place with two disciplines
come together and I think inter
specifically would be biotech and
blockchain like that Venn diagram yeah
overlap and the multidisciplinary could
mean two or three or four or five or six
disciplines in that in that Venn diagram
Center where that's a big part of again
I think augmenting people's perception
and civilizations perception to have as
much nuance and perspective as possible
you I've actually considered this what
do you think about Allen nuance sake on
what do you guys I feel like there's
more to you than new lows I think if
more of civilization could get behind
that the word of nuance and actually
practice it in a meaningful way yeah I
think we could prosper faster but yeah
now how about Allen multidisciplinary
suck yeah just okay I'm continuing yes
yes okay
so what I really wanted to ask is like
if you hadn't gone the route of seeing
things as an entrepreneur if you had
gone if your life had gone a different
way I'm sure you would have ended up in
a similar place but maybe is there
something else that speaks to you as
like the way the another way you could
have gone or another lens that like you
really want to dive into more in the
future
mmm-hmm like some other disciplines some
other way of seeing the world okay you
want
I have hope I think I have the answer
here okay I'm glad that it came so
quickly it means maybe it's um maybe
it's actually extremely young to me so
two things there the the first thing is
that I when you say that if you did not
do simulation and what you're doing
right now you know
maybe you'd be in a similar place and
some sort of other area and whatnot
my thought about that is sure maybe but
I think it was extremely easy for any of
these variables to be tweaked just such
to where I would have stayed where I was
born in Sioux Falls South Dakota my
entire life
yeah and that was quite easy or stayed
and finished college at the University
of Minnesota in Minneapolis and then
stayed in Minneapolis and went to
Chicago or went back to Sioux Falls or
whatever that any of those small tweaks
in the variables would have ended me up
in a place that I think would not have
been maximizing my truest potential into
the world and so here I am in a place
where I feel like I am truly maximizing
my truest potential it's because I
refused to conform to the principles of
normalization that are permeating
civilization in every single way that
you know stay near stay near where you
were born near your family and your
friends and the people that you know go
to the college that you want to go to go
for four years even if you don't know
what you want to do and follow these
normal get a job that's nine-to-five you
know make enough money so you can buy a
house have kids and family I say it with
drudgery not because it is a drudger
aestheticism oast meaningful to them
fantastic you are your own color on the
color wheel as am i and not one color is
better than the other but what's
interesting is not enough people know
that this color even exists the
entrepreneurial color the offbeat path a
lot of kids aren't even introduced to
the fact that they don't have to go to
college they can go and execute their
ideas starting at the age of 10 into the
world they can start executing at super
young ages no shout out to Joe Josie
this 16 year old down in Los Angeles
that it's been executing so she was like
freaking six or eight learning how to
act and dance and sing and do wow and be
a businessperson and now she's rockin
down in Los Angeles and has millions of
people that are following her and
subscribed to her and you know um and
and and she's a very inspirational young
person that's like you know does the
whole dream thing if you can see it you
can be it you know believe in yourself
and achieve things as a jens ii this is
really important to 16 teaching like two
to 14 year olds this stuff at the gens
ease so my point is is that can you
imagine if more people knew about what
there's a couple points here if a people
knew about the ability to pursue what
was on the offbeat
path that they saw the 99% walking down
the path or a 95 percent or 90 or 80%
bifurcated across trifer catered across
a bunch of her pass then they saw a
different path that they didn't note
that they could see until a mentor told
them about it or until they watched
someone else like gary vaynerchuck talk
about the fact that just shatter through
the normal conformist principles and go
find your own [ __ ] to do and execute
execute execute daily that that that
lead has led me to a great point of
self-actualization also there are I
believe potentially potentially a lot of
different multiverses going on a lot of
different universes occurring that have
these Allen's in them the Allen that
stayed in Sioux Falls is actually exists
in a different universe right now down
that stated mini ops finish college
still in the Allen that left the Bay
Area because he was pissed off about how
hard it was to be an entrepreneur
I talked abouts a little bit of show I
was 22 23 24 it was just so stressful
being an entrepreneur in the Bay Area
and I wasn't patient I wasn't patient I
was like I want to get there so fast the
one I get there so fast but the journey
is the most important part the journey
is the most important part I think
that's something that's true in a lot of
people's lives even if they're not going
the entrepreneurial route going for that
shade that wonderful Allen color yeah I
think like people go I see
I see this thing up here like this is my
goal I want to be a scientist I want to
be like a big author I want to be
whatever like their that was in foot
view of where they want to be is and
they see where they are right now and
they go this is daunting this is scary
this is this is terrifying and like they
that's really challenging for a lot of
people to go okay
so here's this here's the next step yep
here's the next three steps after that
and like to honestly to see people who
have done that it's so important and to
like meet people and understand that
there's a path from A to Z and you can't
do it in one leap like that's not a
thing oh yeah it's called here it is I
just want to show it to people it's
called the valley of death of
entrepreneurship it's like it's like
kind of like this basically in a very
small way to explain it just like you
have this amazing wild imagination of a
creative endeavor you want to execute
into the world and then it's the journey
which is the hardest part which is the
valley of death because so many ideas
die in that section which is what I was
just referencing um the idea that you or
your tree or you're trying to go and and
um and execute like I was in the barrier
and then in the different multiverse in
a different universe there is an Allen
that is currently roaming Europe or
China or whatever other part of the
world because Allen just pulled the plug
out of the rat race and Silicon Valley
and went somewhere else is that Alan
differently meaningfully actualized sure
he would be in Sioux Falls to etc so
that was one part of the answer yeah I'm
glad you brought this up the valley guys
the valley that's so freakin important
Nick I'm really happy you brought it up
and another part of the answer to your
question is if Alan was not doing
simulation Alan would be
and I do believe this is something that
I will be doing in the future with what
I built with this project hopefully is
that I really want to actually architect
I want to be a planetary architect so
look at Nick's face so I want to be
planning it to your architect that means
that I want to I want to architect the
frameworks of civilization that enable
maximal prosperity both as individuals
and also as a collective so that's what
I would be doing slash we want to be
doing in the future along with this so
it's like the stadium's plus those
creative warehouses which we didn't
really get to touch on but yeah the idea
of where these stadiums are going to
have these you know these groups of
people that go they get access to these
massive centers that enable them with
all the technologies and again this is
not based on ownership this is based on
decentralization the centralization
decentralize artificial intelligences
that are able to move about and and help
with these things but the creative
execution of these ideas that come from
these stadiums are the ideas that do the
thing that I just described about
maximizing civilizational prosperity and
being a planetary architect so the
people everyone is in that sense doing
it but some people are doing it on a
very individual scale where they go and
spend a lot of one-on-one time with
another human and then they go tell me
about your life how can I help you how
can I bring value to it cetera and a lot
of people also do this on a scale of
like how can i impact seven point seven
billion people in the next two years
with a really crazy cool idea and so
there's all these different scales of
civilizational planetary architecture so
anyway yeah how do I answer this is I
think you know we've been going for a
while we have how many more Q's my last
question oh this is last one this is the
one I promised you
this is the one I promised you you
really should expect oh gosh okay but I
still don't know what this so okay do
this do you know in sock oh god I know
what it is so there we are in a computer
simulation I'm glad I'm being asked this
question interesting thanks for thanks
Nick for asking this mm-hmm we started
interestingly hinting at this last night
in conversation and I thought it was
really good that we started hinting at
it this way
I like thinking of the universe in code
and if we think about the universe in
code things kind of start making sense
about how reality exists and let's take
an example that your heart beats 86,000
ish times per day you can quite easily
run that as a line of code beat 86,000
times per day unless or you know if you
can have exercise occurs beat more times
per day if decreased heart rate occurs
from deep periods of meditation then
less times per day etc I can almost
guarantee you that you are going to have
a line of code that says that you're
gonna urinate three times today
you're gonna eat three times today
you're gonna brush your teeth twice
today you're gonna take one shower today
you're gonna blink ten twenty thirty
thousand dish times today you're going
to do these things a certain amount of
times per day it's kind of interesting
so
are there is is there a certain let's
talk about this also on a solar system
esque scale is the earth 93 million
miles from the star yes ish that's what
we call this you call these miles
million miles is gravity 9.8 meters per
second squared
yeah okay we've called these things with
these labels okay we see how these
things are kind of codified they're
coded and if you can code the distance
of the planet from the star and the
brightness of the star and the size of
the star in the mass of the planet and
the
the actual atoms so again we're just now
we're breaking down the periodic table
breaking down we're carbon-based beings
how there's oxygen that we breathe etc
there's so much this it's it's difficult
to try and summarize in the most concise
way possible and I think the easiest way
for me to summarize it is how I just
started trying to put it into pieces
which is just thinking about the
universe as code makes the inquiry of
simulation theory more interesting to
try and understand because when we get
to that point that we were talking about
earlier and yet though when we were
talking about singularity that there are
going to be interesting simulations that
we run ourselves and we will learn a lot
about ourselves when we run those
simulations if you can code what it's
like for a rock earth to orbit a star a
burning nuclear fusion reactor if you
can code that encode 13.8 billion years
of evolution and code the 4.5 billion
years of evolution of Earth and code the
last 6 million years of evolution of the
human that if you encode these things
and all of a sudden you see the exact
point in 2018 this year that we're at
and you're like wow civilizations the
exact way that our code Iran that it
would predict it to be that's when you
say that's when you say wow how is this
itself potentially not just code so that
would be a nuance driven way to say
think about the universe as code and let
that thought experiment run you into
cool ways of thinking and enjoy the
conversation with other people about it
yeah and last bit on it is how
interesting is it though
that maybe you are leveling up maybe
this is you in your 80 year span here on
earth leveling up and we are your
mission may be to come to earth to help
civilization make sense of itself in the
cosmos and help this civilization
prosper collectively as a union that may
be your mission because I have a strong
feeling that it's my mission and so this
is me leveling up and your leveling up
too
and who knows what will happen afterward
that is my answer this deep woody
what do you would you think of that you
tell me what you thought of that no I
think that it's a uniquely Alan I think
it's a uniquely Alan way to way to
answer it because I think I've
definitely seen like similar approaches
to the question of can we simulating
universe and certainly the famous
example of if we can we probably are one
but the idea of looking at it from from
the top down from the emergent
properties looking down onto the
universe it's interesting I think that I
I think that's a unique twist that it's
it's an Allen way of framing that
question it really is very it we stand
on the shoulders of giants so I've been
you know yeah I hope to bring some sort
of unique perspective to the way that
that we think about these things and I
think glad you glad you resonate with
with it
yeah I think that's what you've done for
the last what is it two hundred and
forty-five
yeah two hundred forty years before this
yeah we're on to 46 46 two four six yeah
and we serve a backlog of
anymore and that's great that's a lot in
a year it's been a lot of fun we'll be
at you know if we're at 500 next year
that means we've kept pace which is
exciting and I think think about how
many brilliant people there are to
feature on this program I'm super
excited to feature more of you brilliant
people on this program and hopefully
inspire more people to care about that
Union together moving forward I love you
Nick and no doubt you'll have trouble
you'll have zero trouble finding 500
more after that yeah yeah totally
totally yeah the guests the guests are
no problem that's uh how long do the you
know how long did the batteries run but
there's um there's it's interesting like
the like the energy inside not yeah the
80 or energy not like the batteries of a
device the just quickly an interesting
thought is uh post-production in many
ways is a very I think potentially in
some ways in especially in long-form
conversation I think post-production is
slightly dying because as you see what's
going on here we have this long-form
nuance driven conversation and we're
switching live between cameras bah bah
bah bah bah bah and it's interesting
because this goes live to YouTube and
Facebook and then it lives there
digitally and we have a recording of my
not but that is done there we don't have
to go behind a computer into premiere
and go and cut for hours and hours and
hours and nitpick and all this kind of
stuff and so I'm just saying that this
medium in itself it's a very fascinating
medium this long-form multi-camera live
stream format because you know how much
easier it's going to be for us to do
hundreds of interviews when it's yeah
I've like this you can sit down for one
hour with 12 different people in a day
you can do 12 interviews in a day if
you're that absolutely
fanatic which I am will eventually get
something crazy like that but point
being is that post production will still
live for other for other yes definitely
especially like movies and stuff at
post-production is a big thing ya know I
think I think to your point like we were
talking earlier about how you spent I
think it was more than eight hours yeah
I was like eight hours from last night
last night yeah like I think it's not
not doing post-production and this live
format itself allows you to drop all of
that let that fade away and really focus
on the content and really focus on your
mission yeah that's right that's right
and I and I it's it's in people that sit
behind computers know how yeah crazy ly
straining it can be for your neck your
back your hips your fingers your eyes to
be behind computer screens and when
you're here you're more you know we're
more flowy were more like you know we
can do whatever you know around and
we're doing we're doing I to I face to
face that's not behind a computer screen
so this is personal it's more personal
and it's you know there's an insert
there interlocutors so there's it's a
dialogue that's going on and there's
empathy and compassion and mental
lattices at play versus a computer
screen so this is totally a future yeah
Nick that was great that was so I think
you unleashed a lot of really powerful
things in me by aging us to do this and
I love you so much for wanting to do
this and caring about me enough to do
this and you are yourself a very
powerful interlocutor a powerful
polymath a powerful human that cares so
much about building a bright future and
I am just blessed to have you as my
and also and also just that you did this
because this it took it took a lot of
powerful things that have been building
up in me over the last year especially
over the last couple of months and we
were able to really synthesize them
quite interestingly in fascinating ways
and get them out yeah and that's what I
normally for other people here yeah I
feel like you do all of this and you are
you're the guy in the editing suite
you're so many of these things and it's
not it's never about you but I think you
have a lot that you can share and I I
knew that I wanted to do this for a
while I think it was six months ago yeah
when I first came up with the idea it
might it might be it might be it might
be longer than that yeah yeah but it was
a while ago
and I I'm not quite sure what it was but
I knew I knew today was when you needed
to do this I'm happy that you I want to
help Alan level up
you have successfully definitely helped
me level of yeah we did a lot of cool
things like the one-to-many and then the
up being of all those ideas going on we
talked about so many cool things and
greatly appreciate you for it any last
thoughts from you I mean I I think that
was it I was gonna say the same of you
okay you have any last thoughts um I
normally just you know close out the
show by telling people how much I [ __ ]
love them and we can we can do that and
spire your people to actually build so
yeah let's let's do that I want to you
know huge shout out to Nick everyone
major shout out to Nick you can follow
Nick on this can follow Nick on Twitter
Nick thank you thank you thank you thank
you very brim in brother
cheers and you you guys can you guys can
follow Nick Nick Twitter's below and
also a thing that Nick's really passion
about FIRST Robotics I really recommend
people to get involved with FIRST
Robotics around the world and I'm very
passionate about it too I was really
thinking about trying to get it to
places in the world that don't have it
yet yeah they're exciting stuff a lot of
a lot of cool stuff can happen when
young girls and boys get to design and
engineer robots cuz and they get to
learn about what they potentially can
care about etc so anyway check out FIRST
Robotics first inspires orgas is the
link there URL and so huge shout out to
Nick love you Nick and for you guys
tuning into this episode I really
appreciate you guys tuning into this
episode it's been a very special one for
me and it's huge thanks to Nick for
making it happen let me know your
thoughts because I know some of you are
frequent frequenters on our channel and
you have heard content from us before
and that we'd love to hear from you
about what your thoughts were about me
unleashing myself in this way and about
you know Nick here I have for a long
time wanted Nick to be you know as we
develop this out from and from a
dialogue between two people eventually
we'll build this out to be able to host
three or four people simultaneously
in multidisciplinary format and Nick is
one of the people that I definitely want
to have with us in those in this multi
person sit downs for the newbies as well
for people that haven't seen the show
before that are watching this and a lot
of you have commented before about who
is this guy you know and so like you
know Nick's laughing right now because
it's it's very true that like some of
you some of you are like folks guy so
this is a good way for for those that
are new to get to know I guess a bit
more about simulation of a bit
about who I am a bit more about what we
care about when we want her to do in the
world so give us your thoughts to give
us your thoughts in the comments below
everyone we'd love to hear from you
there is a there is a telegram link
there's a ways to subscribe to us and
follow what we're doing but there's also
a telegram link for a chat that we have
a community chat that week where we talk
about really interesting questions and
answers to them and it's a really
nuanced driven fun group that what we do
this discussion so joining that if you'd
like if the spirit so moves you and you
are financially capable it'd be awesome
to have you join us as a patreon a
patron or do cryptocurrency those links
are below as well we need to do get some
new lavell ear mics that have higher
quality need to get some new LED lights
instead of our old 500 watt lights that
are ridiculously not environmentally
conscious so we need your help in
scaling our impact and interviewing
people from around the world that have
invited us to go out there and do that
and most importantly out of all of this
information on the closing segment is
going build the future we just talked
about top-down processing last night
about goal-setting and conscientiousness
and distraction-free life this
distraction for you as possible with
your focus build maximize your own
creative potential into the world to
bring value to civilization I love you
all I love you all thank you so much for
joining us and we'll see you soon
everyone peace